- [Narrator] If you want to conduct
experiments like this in space,
- We are trying to grow edible plants.
- [Narrator] this is
the only place to do it.
But soon, the International
Space Station will have company.
In April, China launched the core part
of its new space station, called Tiangong,
which means heavenly palace in Chinese.
(speaking in foreign language)
- This is a brand new
modular space station.
There are many exciting things about it.
- [Narrator] China says Tiangong
will be up and running by 2022,
becoming a research spacecraft
that will orbit Earth
alongside the nearly 23-year-old
International Space Station.
NASA and its partner countries have agreed
that the older spacecraft
will operate through 2024,
though its future after that is unclear.
- If the International Space
Station retires in 2024,
the Chinese space station
will be the only permanent space
station in low Earth orbit.
It means that China
could have a very strong
global presence and influence.
- [Narrator] So here's what's
on China's new space station
and how it compares with
the international one.
The first thing you have to know
about China's space station,
it's building it all by itself,
and some of the reasons for
that go back about a decade.
- China is not part of the
International Space Station.
- [Narrator] Quentin
Parker is the Director
of the Laboratory for Space Research
at the University of Hong Kong.
He's been researching space
science for over four decades.
- They're primarily political
around issues of trust
and technology transfer,
which is driven principally
by the United States.
- [Narrator] Since 2011, China
has been excluded by U.S. law
from working with NASA.
As a result, China's astronauts
have not been allowed
to set foot on the
International Space Station,
which is a collaboration
with five space agencies.
China's foreign ministry
said that the U.S.
is judging an upright
man with a petty mind.
- In some ways, it's been
extremely beneficial to China,
because it's given China the impetus
and the political will to move forward
with their own very
ambitious space endeavors.
- [Narrator] And China's
space station ambition
has been 30 years in the making.
In 2003, it's sent its
first astronauts to space,
making it the third country
after the U.S. and Russia to do that.
Less than a decade later,
China said it successfully
launched two test modules
which are the basis for
any space station design.
- These modules are then put
together a bit like Lego.
The reason in modular, of course,
is you can't put the
whole thing up in one go.
You have to put it up bit
by bit using many launches.
- [Narrator] The
International Space Station
currently has 16 modules,
whereas China only has one in orbit.
But eventually, Tiangong
will be made up of three.
- It's only about a quarter or so
of the size of the current
International Space Station.
Three people can live on
the Chinese space station at the moment.
- [Narrator] Compare
that with the six people
usually on board the
International Space Station,
or in 2009 when there was a record total
of 13 astronauts at one time.
And China could potentially
reach that capacity too,
just by adding more modules.
Thanks to this design, the
International Space Station
has been an evolving project since 1998.
- So if one module has
failed catastrophically,
or it's no longer cutting edge,
you can detach it and
just reattach a new one.
- [Narrator] While the
Tiangong spacecraft is smaller,
China says it's equipped with
more advanced technology.
- When you're the last kid on the block,
do you have the opportunity to do things
at the last minute with
the best technology around.
- [Narrator] And one of them is a system
that helps power Tiangong
with solar panels.
(speaking in foreign language)
The electricity generated
from the panel wings
essentially helps keep the lights on.
But one unique part about China's setup
is that it also powers
the space craft's propulsion technology.
So even though Tiangong still
uses regular fuel propellants
like the International Space Station,
China says it doesn't have to use as much
to stay afloat in orbit.
- If you're not using a liquid
or solid fuel propellant
for your propulsion, then
you're not carrying that weight,
then that's a saving.
- [Narrator] China's space agency
says its propulsion system
is about five times more
efficient and powerful
than the International Space Station's,
which is a gas guzzler.
- So we're gonna fire the engines
in the aft end of the space station.
- [Narrator] Consuming about
nine tons of fuel annually
to stay in orbit.
Another piece of equipment
that the International
Space Station doesn't have,
a tag-a-long space telescope.
It's called Xuntian,
which means heavenly cruiser in Chinese,
and will orbit parallel
to the Space Station.
- A bit like the Hubble Space Telescope,
but this will have an
enormously large camera
which can look up to 300
times the field of view
of the Hubble Space Telescope in one hit.
- [Narrator] The Chinese
telescope will be able to refuel
and be serviced by directly
docking at Tiangong,
unlike the Hubble Telescope,
which because it orbits on its own,
requires astronauts to fly
in from Earth for repairs.
And one day, China space telescope
could be used by other countries,
because China has said
it's new space station
is designed for collaborations.
- So for China, international
cooperation in space
means its space capacity has legitimacy,
and second, it can build influence.
- [Narrator] Namrata Goswami
is an independent researcher
who's been studying global space policy
for more than 20 years.
- [Namrata] With the completion
of the Chinese space station
by 2022, that will be
a competitive alignment
for countries that want to choose
which space station they would
launch their experiments on.
- [Narrator] Goswami says
China's decision-making process
could be very different
from the International Space Station,
which requires consensus
among its partners.
- Chinese space station is
going to be operated by China.
Any decision to allow a
particular scientific experiment
to be conducted in the
Chinese space station
will of course be taken by China.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] And more of these
decisions could come soon,
since Tiangong is set
to be completed by 2022.
(speaking in foreign language)
And that milestone is another
one in just a few years,
in addition to landing on
the far side of the Moon,
to sending a rover to roam Mars.
- It is very clear that
China's investment in space
is about turning China
into a aerospace power.
- [Narrator] But China
won't be the only one
left to fill the vacancy
when the International Space
Station heads into retirement.
NASA is leading a plan
to launch an outpost
that will work like the
International Space Station
but instead orbit the Moon.
And Russia has indicated
that it could launch its
own space station by 2030.
- Space is always seen
as a part of geopolitics.
The competition that is ongoing
is which country has the more
attractive space capacity
in low Earth orbit and beyond?